let's go next to janik from las vegas uh
yannick how's vegas these days
david pakman my can you hear me i can
okay i have one of those fears i always
see how uh
when the connection is bad how much it
uh upsets you so it saddens me yeah but
no our connection's solid right now
so i've got a light-hearted kind of
funny question for you so
i'm a financial advisor um
i have some clients who
i don't want to say anything too
specific but
imagine some of the craziest people you
see on your show like they are cuckoo
for cocoa puffs yeah but
i help them manage their money okay so
some of my friends like joke around and
they're like you're basically a candace
owens of wealth management so
my question is is like
what like what's your opinion on me you
know having those clients inevitably
listen if a financial advisor is so
uh
attached to
not helping people
whose political views are at odds with
their own
it's up to you to decide i'm only gonna
manage money for progressives like you
could do that i don't have any kind of
opinion on that i mean i think you know
there's lots of jobs where i mean could
a mechanic say we only fix cars for
progressives like sure i could but at a
certain point it's sort of like what are
we trying to do and if your goal is
simply like okay let me build my
business as an advisor and just help as
many people as possible even if some of
those people will take their gains and
donate it to causes i don't want you
it's it's ultimately your call i don't
have any views
right i'm i'm gonna tell them you said
that and also
funny note kind of not funny
during the last election i talked to a
lot of people
who were so deluded by this you know joe
biden is a communist joke you know
he's going to crash the market
and i explained to them like listen
every article i'm reading that's coming
out
is basically saying like this guy's
policies are not going to be much
different than trump anyway
and these
a lot of people i watch them sell
millions of dollars out of the market
and i'm like
well yannick i'm curious why you didn't
say something else what if you told them
the truth which is
stocks tend to perform better when a
democrat is president than when a
republican is president going back to
the beginning of the market i mean that
it's an undeniably accurate statement
what would they say if you told them
that
i think
i just think if you're getting into
specific facts like that they're just
going to not
believe it essentially so they don't
trust you as a financial advisor
i think a lot of people let their
political leanings
over affect their investment decisions
right no i don't i don't doubt that but
i mean it would just be interesting if
presumably they trust you to manage
their money and they go i'm thinking of
selling everything because a democrat is
going to win if you go oh no no the
market does fine under democrats you'd
think most people would be like oh all
right i won't do anything then
right i and i also think it's funny
because you know i talk with some of my
buddies and we're like
looking back i wonder like if i asked
these same people do like do i think
they'd be checked into reality that like
oh i was wrong or
are they gonna find some like oh the
democrats are they're rigging the stock
market too so
it it's just a funny thing but
um i'm gonna get out of here my brother
i really appreciate the time i'm a
massive fan of your show so this this
was really an honor it's the first time
i ever uh jumped in the chat so
beautiful
and things are things are okay in vegas
i potentially will be back there in a
few weeks for my first it's going to be
my triumphant return since the start of
the pandemic
you know it's it's good so i just moved
i grew up in vegas i went to school um
at georgetown university
i moved to new jersey and i've been
working
there ever since and then
i just recently moved back
to las vegas okay i went independent as
an advisor
the biggest
change but like besides that
there's like kind of everyone wears
masks and
excuse me there's never really been any
mask mandates in jersey
lately
so i'm kind of getting used to like
everyone here wearing the masks all the
time but
david people here are strapped to the
teeth and what i mean is
the amount of guns
that people have here
it's it's just such a juxtaposition to
what i was used to in
new jersey
at this point
you know so just like seeing people just
open carry at the albertsons you know
it's just it's just a wacky wacky thing
if if you haven't seen it in a while you
know yep no doubt about it all right
yannick thank you for the call
a real honor my brother have a good one
there's yannick from vegas let's take a
very short break if you're holding don't
hang up because i'm going right back to
the phones in a moment science has shown
us that lowering your body temperature
at night helps you sleep i can't sleep
in a hot room that's why i love our
sponsor chilly sleep which makes
customizable climate controlled sleep
solutions to sleep better their flagship
products are the uhler sleep system and
the cube sleep system which is what i
have both are hydro powered temperature
controlled luxury mattress pads you can
make them as cold as 55 degrees
fahrenheit if you wanted you could go as
hot as 115 degrees
i like the cooler option i keep mine at
60 degrees and it gives me a great cool
night of sleep no feeling hot no more
sweating i'm falling asleep faster and
it pairs perfectly with chili sleeps
weighted chili blanket which keeps you
cold on top too and for a limited time
chili sleep has a special offer just for
my audience go to
chilisleep.com pacman to learn about the
exclusive discount the link is down
below